how are you feeling i feel good i feel
relieved
i don't have to hopefully get i can get
sleep now
i paced back and forth before i even
went into the courtroom
and i sat in one spot in the corner the
same spot by the trash can i always said
it and i prayed
and i prayed for like 30 minutes and the
verdict came back
when the jurors came out guilty guilty
and guilty and i just couldn't believe
it
because african-american people we never
get justice we feel like it's just us
how does it feel that your brother
changed the world it feels good
i think about how he's a symbol
for justice i'm speaking out
for him uh the world has united around
him
because they all knew they seen
something that shouldn't have happened
he should still be here he had a man
sit on his knee on his neck for over
nine minutes but
as we stand in solidarity with all the
protesters people all around the world
we are so happy and i want to thank
everybody from italy
london britain ghana germany
places everywhere because they all dm me
they all said i hope you get justice for
your brother
and i believed in them and like i
believed in my lord and savior jesus
christ
we have faith and we will stick we will
get justice and we got it today
do you feel that you now just want do
you feel that you now
have your brother back well does this
now give you time to grieve
what do you make of it yeah we agree we
yeah that's it
hey just today we're going to celebrate
today yeah
but tomorrow we're going to keep
fighting
yeah we're going to keep fighting we're
going to keep fighting this is my man
still
yeah we're going to fight this fight
we're going to fight the series
and what's what does the fight involve
justice devante wright devonte wright
brianna taylor pamela turner philando
castilla
i mean there's so many that we could
name that didn't get justified
we want we want the justice department
to look at eric garner's case orlando
castillo case all the cases that were
swept under the rug by the
last administration we want all the
cases open because murder don't have a
statute of limitation
so that's what we're here for to make
sure that those nights stay alive and
justice for brianna taylor justice for
eric gardner we want justice
for everybody just like we got it for
george i mean this is just the beginning
that's where we at
and at the end of the day we know when
they say that
george floyd changed the world what
george floyd really changed was the
criminal justice system because before
today
it was exactly that a justice system
being ran by a bunch of damn criminals
so now we see justice
we got faith in the system now you prove
change can happen that's right that's
right that's right
that's right and emma thiel emmett emma
he was the first joker love y'all thank
y'all